economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge comenzamos
hablando de china porque hay algunas
fábricas están cerrando temporalmente
que lo que está pasando allí bueno
básicamente el partido comunista intenta
ser un equilibrio entre el desarrollo
económico y también el cambio climático
específicamente las fábricas y hogares
de china sufren cortes de energía
producto de estrictas medidas de consumo
varios proveedores de appple y teclas
suspendieron la producción en algunas
fábricas lo que supondría el riesgo del
suministro de varios productos durante
la temporada alto de los aparatos
electrónicos la causa de los recortes
santiago según economistas en vista
lista se debe a que estos fabricantes
agotaron la cuota de este año antes de
lo planeado también bajaron los
pronósticos de crecimiento económico
para chinas a 4.7 por ciento en vez del
5.1 en el trimestre actual los
fabricantes ya enfrentan escasez de
chips por interrupciones en el envío
debido al cierre global de viajes y
comercios por la pandemia china también
sufre una crisis de energía
la escasez de suministros de carbón el
endurecimiento de los estándares de
emisiones y la demanda de los
fabricantes pasamos a hablar ahora de
alemania porque allí hubo un referendo
en donde votaron a favor de expropiar
las grandes inmobiliarias principalmente
en berlín la capital bueno casi 25
millones de berlineses votaron a favor
de que el senado redacte un proyecto de
ley para expropiar alrededor de 240 mil
propiedades que pertenecen a grandes
inmobiliarias el malestar popular ha
crecido porque hubo novia la empresa de
alquiler más grande de alemania anunció
la compra de un rival más pequeño del
guaje así se creó un gigante
inmobiliario con unos 550 mil
apartamentos valorados en casi 100 mil
millones de dólares
francisca jefe ganó como alcaldesa en
berlín y aunque rechaza las
expropiaciones aseguró que se deben
respetar los resultados del referéndum
un portavoz de la iniciativa dijo en un
comunicado que ignorar el referendo
sería un escándalo político y agregó que
no se rendirán hasta que se implemente
democratización de los grupos de
vivienda en respuesta el grupo
inmobiliario dijo que las expropiaciones
no resuelven el problema de fondo
pasemos ahora a temas de américa latina'
el gobierno de argentina anunció un
programa para formalizar a las
trabajadoras domésticas de este país un
anuncio importante y favorable para
ellas bueno así es sobre todo en este
país en donde el trabajo doméstico en la
tercera rama de inserción laboral para
las mujeres el programa de nombres
registradas estará abierto durante
octubre noviembre y diciembre el
objetivo reducir la informalidad en el
sector de las trabajadoras de casas
particulares dando incentivos por
ejemplo santiago el estado va a
subsidiar por seis meses consecutivos
entre el 30% y el 50% de los salarios de
los trabajadores de casas particulares
que tengan 12 o más horas semanales para
controlarlo se va a abrir una cuenta
bancaria a nombre del trabajador donde
se depositará el beneficio y se
controlará que el empleador deposite el
resto del salario los empleadores
deberán pagar los aportes de las
contribuciones y el seguro de riesgo de
trabajo esto se parte de una serie de
anuncios económicos que la
administración de alberto fernández
realiza tras la derrota que sufrió hace
dos semanas en las elecciones primarias
que son previa a las legislativas del 14
de noviembre pasó a preguntarle ahora
jorge por un nuevo estudio que indica
que los países que son considerados
pobres económicamente van a demorarse
tres años en recuperar la economía
después de la pandemia si en números
negativos realmente este es un informe
elaborado por la conferencia de las
naciones unidas para el comercio y el
desarrollo asegura que al menos 46
economías del mundo tardarán como medio
3 años en recuperarse producto del
impacto de la pandemia el grupo de
países menos desarrollados podrían
incluso tardar más de 5 años en
recuperar la renta per cápita que sus
poblaciones tenían en 2019 en esos
países santiago stangl a haití somalia
zimbabue sudán entre otros que forman
parte de la lista que fue creada por
naciones unidas hace 50 años se estima
que en estos países vivió más de la
octava parte de la población mundial y
representan menos de la centésima parte
del comercio global hablemos ahora de
los indicadores muy bien la bolsa del
mundo iniciaron la semana con reacciones
al aumento del precio del petróleo y los
temores sobre ever grand wall street
cerró mixto después de la volatilidad de
la semana pasada y en américa latina la
bolsa cerraron al alza por la relativa
calma en asia respecto a ever gran y con
esto finalizamos esta crónica de
economía muchas gracias jorge por esta
información es todo por el momento aquí
en france24 siga con nosotros buenas
noches
[Música]